[Music]
hello everyone Perry back you're in Park
City at the supper suite with another
exclusive Collider interview I was just
telling Ramallah this one of my favorite
movies thus far in the festival amulet
congratulations I'm so excited for you
guys I genuinely mean it not to know
I've seen quite a bit I can assure you
I've seen quite a bit I am on very
little sleep so this one is is really
something else but a lot of people out
there do not know what the movie is
about so I must give this duty to you
can you give everyone the brief synopsis
also so I know how far to go questions
right now yeah I'm under strict
instructions not to reveal certain
things so it's it's a film about a young
man called Thomas played by Alec who has
been recently been fighting in a war but
is come to London and is suffering very
badly he's you know living essentially
on the streets and having very bad
flashbacks to his time in the war he has
some sort of PTSD he he meets a young
woman played by Carla Magda who's living
in a kind of slightly dilapidated house
she's caring for an elderly mother who
we start to suspect might have
supernatural qualities and she seems to
be in a very unfortunate and difficult
situation and tomash comes into their
house and a love story between them
starts to thrive and then the film takes
a different turn and extraordinary and
hopefully unexpected things happen job
well done I you know hopefully that'll
pique interest out there and you didn't
spoil a thing your feature directorial
debut here that's a very important step
for a new director why this particular
story for that well I I guess I had been
very intrigued by the idea of writing in
this genre but in such a way as to maybe
explode or subvert some of the tropes
that you see in the genre particularly
perhaps to do with the way that men and
women and their relationships are
portrayed in the genre and
so I went into it with a particular idea
of maybe playing with what qualities a
man would have in a film like this and
what qualities a woman would have in a
film like this and maybe trying to be a
bit playful with those I also just
really love special effects and I wanted
to work with like creatures and do
something that felt like it was a horror
film that was moving there's a lot of
body horror in it but there's also
creatures and that there's something
kind of of the fantasy and Gothic
elements of the film as well and those
and I wanted to do something that felt
like it was kind of exploring different
kinds of genre horror genres in that in
there and there may be excellent
practical impacts in this one
are you both horror genre fans or is
this kind of something new for you at
all well I wouldn't call myself a fan of
horror films but I've seen my fair share
of horror films but as an actor of
course I'm interested in working in
different genres and try to understand
more how it's on set and how a film is
being done and the specificity of the
genre and this was a great opportunity
being the fact that I've got I received
the script for Ramallah and I read it
and did it treat me a lot because there
are a lot of there were a lot of
unanswered questions in the film and I
wanted to investigate more about that
and yeah I think I mean how about you
big into horror is this new territory
for you I guess it's new in a way I find
it I like it because it's the kind of
thriller thriller horror and it's a
psychological horror in that sense and
they're always a sense of mystery with
that and and unexpectedness and I that's
what I kind of like within this story
and within my character and so I always
kind of for some reason I'm drawn to the
more of maybe unexpected kind of
mysterious things yeah
I have to tell you I'm a huge horror fan
and I can watch just about anything
happen on screen and not flinch wetlands
might have scarred me for life I talked
about it with one of my friends all the
time and she just laughs that I can't
watch that but I could watch everything
in the horror genre you know or in a
different way it has never left my mind
from the day I saw it and you go from
that and obviously a lot came in between
but to something like this and it's just
like an incredible range that I can't
believe and even just in this movie in
particular you both have to show off an
extreme amount of range as these
characters go through their arc I assume
you did not shoot in sequence so what is
kind of the prep process before you jump
into each and every scene to make sure
you are there and you're hitting the
precise moment in their journey you have
to Ramallah was really helpful with with
this process because she's an actor as
well and she really knows how actors
work and what do they need and I mean
before every scene we shot it way out of
chronology so it didn't make any sense
at one point what what since we were
shooting that day but Romulan was really
helpful because it before every single
scene that we shot we wanted to make
sure that we know where the character is
and what part of the story is and what
does he know by now and what is it what
he doesn't know and we tried to keep the
this ambiguity and mystery around the
scenes that that we shot so yeah thank
you for being so helpful I mean I
couldn't have done it with without her
and without Carla as well because I mean
there was a good chemistry between and
on set I think the the crew was most of
it female crew I think 70% or 80% of the
crew was female and the atmosphere on
set was quite everybody was so there and
so into the film and into the story and
so thoughtful and of each other and I
really love that it's an important thing
to have with such heavy
I'm just curious were you guys exhausted
by that in and of itself by the end of a
shooting day and then what do you kind
of do to you know shake it off and
recharge for the next day because it
doesn't seem like there's an easy beat
in this entire movie well the thing is
when the shooting day ends it doesn't
you don't end the work because when you
get when go home you have to look at the
scenes that you're about to should the
next day or the or the next couple of
days to know that you're prepared to
know where you are so it kind of keeps
going it's not only twelve hours a day
it goes on also when you go home and
think about the next day and what you've
done so yeah it might be tricky
sometimes but you have you just have to
go along with it I want to go back to
what you were saying about the crew was
it a deliberate choice for you to seek
out a female collaborators and then also
just with the environment on said what
do you think are I guess the the pillars
of a really comfortable environment on
set that brings out the best work and
everyone around you I mean I find it
this is a difficult question to answer
sometimes because deliberate it's like I
didn't say it has to be all women you
know I just I think because I am a woman
I always wanted to see a list with a
mixture of men and women on it so with
every department head when I met them I
met both men and women for every kind of
head of department and I think maybe
because of the particular themes of the
film some of some of the women
particularly wanted to work on the film
and you know I ended up having the most
incredible team of artistic
collaborators on the film you know our
director of photography was female a lot
of her team were women our production
designer was a woman my composer was a
woman like and and all of those
relationships I think you regardless of
their sex were just you know we were
just able to kind of talk as artists and
that that it sort of became irrelevant
past the point of the initial meeting
where I think there were some some times
the woman who had read the script were
particularly excited to work on it yeah
can I ask you some geeky tech questions
because one of the things that really
strikes me about the movie
is how different each location feels
just in terms of you know shooting style
the lenses you use so can you break that
down a little and the kind of
conversations you had with those
department heads to achieve that yeah it
was mainly my relationship with Laura
Bellingham our DP that was the
concentration of how to kind of create
those different worlds and fields and
landscapes I was always very clear I
wanted to have three different very
different shooting styles you know the
the London is shot as though it were a
drama or contemporary drama there's a
lot of hand held it feels very it's a
naturalism its total realism inside of
the house we have very much classic
horror so we were looking at the tenant
we looked a lot of possession and we
looked a lot of things with quite
constructed cinematography and then the
flashbacks I think I wanted to have
slightly more the feel of like a kind of
gothic fairy tale so we're then again we
were maybe working more in a kind of
like a Pan's Labyrinth landscape
something that had a bit more kind of
natural and so we used cook lenses for
that for the house and zeiss for the for
the for the flashbacks in the forest and
yeah and it just really extended mainly
to the shooting style how much the shots
were handheld or not and yeah and and
we'd storyboard the whole film but you
know also with the film on this budget
we weren't able to secure the location
very very far in advance so sometimes we
had to be flexible with the storyboards
and the only set we had was the there
was only one room in the house that is a
set so that was the only sort of space
that we were really able to kind of
completely control like the house like
two weeks before but there might be
stressful with such a primary location
it was unbelievably stressful yes
okay one silly question for you because
food plays a big part in this movie and
we play a game call would you rather and
one thing I always like to ask is would
you rather have to eat a lot in the
scene or run a lot in a scene cuz you
got to do it over and over and I feel
like people don't want that scene well
I'm not very good with cardio part you
know because sometimes you you I mean
you don't have to have a full mouth of
food just to get the idea that you you
like the food that you're eating so you
can cheat
sometimes the glamor of making films you
know it looked amazing it was kind of a
stew with me no it was alright it was
alright yeah but after a while you just
really need it but yeah so I'd rather
eat thank you guys ruined home cooking
and not home cooking for me but in a way
where you absolutely earn it so job well
done in that department I want to know a
little bit about shooting in that house
because the house - the Attic I believe
was a practical location so how much
were you guys able to move around
because I got the impression that it
might have been tighter quarters in
there to me felt very much like my house
because it felt it was I came in it was
everything was dressed downstairs and we
shot basically all the scenes downstairs
and then we moved upstairs and then we
decorated that so it felt like a
transition for the upper levels and it
felt there very organic because felt
like it was lived in so you could like
sit around your couch and kind of see
how that how that feels and it's kind of
important to to embrace a location so to
make it yours just as much as you make I
don't know a piece of cloth yours or the
clothing you're wearing or whatever um
so that was actually very nice because
we shot there for quite a long time so
you go back every day to the same
location you don't not changing location
that can be distressful to change
location all the time because you like
constantly adapting so that was one
steady thing that was nice to have and
anything in the house yeah I thought it
would never end at one point you know
the house is it's like a big character
in the film and it's shooting on
location it's like it's exciting because
it brings some Morgan City in film and
the house itself it's a London house and
it was cold and damp all the time and it
was yeah so we spend I think we spend
almost two and a half weeks or three
weeks in the house
so yeah at one point you get that
feeling I got that feeling that it will
never end that will be there also a
resting room like where we can retreat I
was like there was no reprieve outside
was there any tents or something where
you could get out and hang out outside
the house had Japanese knotweed I don't
know if you have this in America it's
like a terrible invasive plant in
England which means that like we weren't
allowed into the garden because it's
good poison and I couldn't believe the
house was originally not like that it
was dressed because it didn't look
dressed she did an amazing work the set
design we did we did for a long time in
the pre-production have a different
location which was a much bigger house
more like a mansion like its small kind
of mansion and we lost it to another
production and actually it meant that
Francesca was allowed able to do a lot
more to our house in terms of the
colours and glass changing the glass and
the doors and things like that which in
a way meant we were had much better
control of the kind of color palette
inside the house and we would have been
able to have in a bigger location so it
kind of worked out that's always how it
goes I don't know how far I can push it
with the practical effects but I do want
to know about you know working with it
designing some of them what's what's
safe territory to not go too far in that
department I mean I guess I guess it's
easier for us to talk about the stuff
with the blood effects okay then the
creature work that's been here yeah we I
had never done anything like that as an
actor so so I mean I I was working in a
very kind of new thing and you know I
met the team who were doing the
practical effects and my understanding
was that this was this kind of you know
unknown
landscape to me probably filled with
highly technical kind of equipment but
actually it's just a tube and it's just
a guy and that guy just pumps the thing
and the blood comes out and I think it
involved a lot of tubes being taped to
you in intimate places which we onions
you did once make one thing for like a
whole day which was probably I think
like your happiest day ever yeah yeah I
would remember I will remember that day
from my whole life yeah it's weird cuz
you're kind of just shouting it like
from behind the camera you're just going
like blow into the tube harder and you
think people have been saying that now
for like hundred years how is film you
know with practical effects the
technology is like the same either you
blow into the tube really hard or you
blow softly and that's I feel like
that's are a really good tease to end
the film portion of the conversation
thank you guys so much for your time
today and again a big congratulations
the team behind amulet check out my
review of the movie on collider.com it's
a good one also big thanks to the kind
folks over Akio we're at the supper
suite in Park City because of them so
huge thanks to them for making these
interviews happen do not leave this one
without liking and sharing it we'll have
more from Park City for you real soon